[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're in the heat of all the planning
right now which is it's fun it's a good
time but uh that is fun okay what are
some of the like must-haves or things
that you're excited about we're doing it
here in nashville we can throw a party
we throw parties quite often and our
biggest goal is to just throw the most
fun party for everybody so good music
and drinks
well those party planning skills likely
came in handy when lily scored her first
ever academy of country music nomination
thanks to her debut project stronger
than i am congratulations on your very
first acm
nomination oh my gosh it's overwhelming
i mean i only signed a record deal 13
months ago i feel a little uh
humbled and overwhelmed and out of place
but it's it's amazing
[Applause]
when you hear
new female artist of the year what goes
through your mind honestly just all the
people that i look up to a lot that have
won this award in the past and uh my
biggest thing is just trying to be a
movement and not a moment so i hope that
we're around for the rest of my life and
the rest of country music's life
[Music]